اعلن المدعي العام في مدينه نيويوركا هيئه
محلفين كبرى في منهج صوتت لصالح توجيه
اتهام لترامب في خطوه ضمن تحقيق بشان
التستر على دفعه اموالا لاسكات ممثله
اباحيه من اجل تغيير مسار تحقيق قضائي هذه
التطورات القانونيه تضع حمله الانتخابيه
لنيل ترشيح الحزب الجمهوري في انتخابات
2024 على المحرك
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما الابعاد القانونيه
والسياسيه للملاحقه القضائيه التي يتعرض
لها وكيف بدت خارطه المواقف من هذه الخطوه
التي تعد السابقه في التعامل مع الرؤساء
في الولايات المتحده
ما الانعكاسات مباشره لهذه الخطوه على
المستقبل السياسي لترامب وعامه المشهد
السياسي في البلاد وما الاحتمالات
المتوقعه بخصوص رد الفعل في الشارع
الامريكي كذلك اي تاثير لهذه المحاكمه على
صوره واشنطن ومكانتها الدوليه وهل من
الوارد ان يؤدي انشغال البلاد بهذه الشؤون
الداخليه الى تراجعها في اي من الملفات
الاقليميه والدوليه
[موسيقى]
هي سابقه في التاريخ السياسي للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لاول مره يستعد رئيس
امريكي لمواجهه اتهامات جنائيه هو الامر
الذي يرى متابعون ان له تاثيرا يشمل ترامب
وطموحاته الانتخابيه بل وصوره الولايات
المتحده امام مواطنيها والمجتمع الدولي
كل تعليقا على المسار القضائي الذي يعنيه
ان توجيه الاتهام
لاضطهاد سياسي وتدخل في الانتخابات على
اعلى مستوى في التاريخ واضاف الرئيس
الامريكي السابق انه يعتقد ان ملاحقته
ستاتي بنتائج عكسيه على الرئيس جو بايدن
اما بايدن فقال من جانبه انه لا تعليق
لديه بشان توجيه الاتهام
وزعيم الديمقراطيين في مجلس الشيوخ تشومر
اكد ان يخضع للقوانين التي يخضع لها كل
امريكي وبامكانه الاستفاده من القانون
وليس من السياسه لتقرير مصيره وفقا
للوقائع
وترقبا لاي تحركات محتمله لانصار ترامب
قالت شرطه نيويورك انها لن تتسامح مع اي
عنف بالتزامن مع اصداري لائحه اتهام
للرئيس السابق مضيفا انها ستراجع خطط
انتشار عناصرها من اجل مواكبه التطورات
الامنيه وقالت الشرطه في مذكره اصدرتها ان
جميع الافراد يجب ان يكونوا مستعدين
للتعبئه خلال عملهم
وللسيناريو الفوضى غير العاديه بحسب
المذكره
[موسيقى]
لمناقشات هذا الموضوع معنا من واشنطن
الدكتور سايمن روزنبرغ رئيس الشبكه
الديمقراطيه الجديده التابعه للحزب
الديمقراطي من ايدهو معنى جون فاند مراسله
شؤون السياسيه في مجله ناشونال ريفيو ومن
واشنطن معنا محمد المنشاوي الكاتب الصحفي
المختص في الشؤون الامريكيه اهلا بكم
جميعا ضيوفنا في ما وراء الخبر ابدا معك
جونسون اذا ملاحقات قضائيه وسط سجال سياسي
نريد ان نفهم العلاقه بين القانون
والسياسي في هذه السابقه
علينا ان نكتشف ذلك لان لائحه الاتهام لم
يتم كشف احوالها حتى الان فليس لدينا اي
تفاصيل عنها لكنني اعتقد
ان الفيلسوف قال امرا ينطبق على ما نفعلهم
قال الذين لا يتذكرون التاريخ سوف يجدون
انفسهم قبل نحو 30 عاما من الان كانت هناك
محاوله عزل برلمانيه للرئيس كلينتن وكان
هناك اجماع بعد ذلك ان فكره وجود محقق خاص
في وزاره العدل هي فكره سيئه بحد ذاتها
لكن قبل عشر سنوات كان هناك جون اد المرشح
الديمقراطي لمصر نائب الرئيس الذي جهه
اليه لائحه
اتهامات بانه جمع اكثر من مليون دولار من
متبرعين من اصدقاء وغير ذلك واستخدم تلك
الاموال لاسكات صوتي عشيقته
وتم توجيه لائحه اتهام اليهم من قبل مدعي
عام جمهوري
وبموافقه وزاره العدل في عهده اوباما
وحكم على اساس ست جرائم
وتم التبرياته بواحده ولم يحسم المحلفون
امر الباقي والكل اتفق على انه كان من
الخطا عمل ذلك لانه تم البحث قضيه طابع
سياسي باطار عدلي الان نحن نكرر الامر
نفسه وهناك قضايا اكثر قوه من القضيه
الموجهه ضد دوله ترامب وهي قضيه هل ان
ترامب قد
وثائق ذات علاقه بالامن القومي طبعا هناك
مشكله في ذلك لان بعد ان رحل بعيدا عن
ناصر نائب الرئيس عثر على وثائق في حوزته
ايضا هذه هي المشكله هنا ورئيس فريق
التحقيق من مكتب ولايه نيويورك استقال في
العام الماضي وقال انكم تسيرون بالاتجاه
الخطا عليكم ان تبحثوا في سجلاتي اعمال
ترامب العقاريه
وسمى هذه القضيه قضيه زومبي اي قضيه الميت
الحي حتى الان نحن لا نعرف لا نعرف تفاصيل
الاتهامات كما ذكرت سيد فاند ولكن ما
نعرفه ان الموقف الرسمي الامريكي
يقول ان ما يحصل هو في اطار قانوني صرف
وان
ما يتم التعامل به مع ترامب هو كاي مواطن
امريكي اخر
ولذلك هل يمكن ان نفصل هذا المشهد عن
ابعاده السياسيه وما خطوره هذا
اعتقد ان هناك عده امور مهمه في هذه
النقاشه
واحدها ان نعرف انه جريمه ارتكبت فعلا
ترامب وزاره العدل قد الوزاره اخلقت خلقت
هذا القضيه سابقه ضد مايكل اثناء رئاسه
ترامب وادانت مايكل وهو دخل السجن
وبالتالي ليس هناك جريمه التركيبه كما
نعرف ان المسؤول الالماني لشركه ايضا في
السجن لاعمال قام بها ضمن منظمه وبالتالي
القول بان ترامبول لحد ما ان هذه شيء عمل
جنوني ويقوم به المدعي العامه ما يقوله
سخيف جدا لا نعلم انه جريمه جريمه كتبت
هذه حقيقه ونعلم ان
الضالع فيها وبالتالي هذه لعبه وانت لعبه
عادله واذا لم تعتقد انها عادله منصف
في المره الاولى وهذه الضجه الان تثور
لانه يرشح نفسه مره ثانيه محمد المنشاوي
وهنا السؤال كيف ترى تعاطي النخب السياسيه
والشارع الامريكي ايضا مع هذه القضيه الان
يعني خصوصا للبعض علامه صحيه في الواقع
الى اي حد هي كذلك امنيه جرس انذار فيما
يتعلق بالحاله السياسيه في الولايات
المتحده ككل
تحيه طيبه اعتقد ان يوم الامس عندما علمنا
ان الرئيس السابق سيتم توجيه اتهامات
جنائيه له هو يوم حزين للسياسه الامريكيه
والامريكا كلها اعتقد ان هناك تسييس كبير
جدا في هذه القضيه ويجب ان ولا يمكن ان
نضعها في اطارها القانوني فقط هذه قضيه
لحدث وقع قبل 17 عاما عندما التقى ترامب
هذه الممثله الاباحيه وحدث بينهما ثم اجدد
الجدال حول هذه القضيه قبل انتخابات 2016
وتم
السكوت في على هذا الموضوع ونجحت
هو يوم حزين لماذا لا يكون
يوم الاداره
الامريكي فعلا تختلط
الحكماء الامريكيون حكماء امريكا يدركون
ان هناك تحديات اكبر من شخصنه هذه القضيه
هناك تحدي الصين التي تلحق بامريكا وربما
تتخطاها في صناعه القادمه وهناك القضايا
كبيره جدا في الداخل الامريكي القضيه عرضت
امام المحاكم الفيدراليه في 2018 ولما
تقدم وزاره العدل على فتح تحقيق وراءت انه
لا يستحق ذلك والمدعي العام السابق في
منهات في ولايه نيويورك ايضا قرر عدم فتح
التحقيق لكن المدعي العام الحالي
قرر في حملات الانتخابيه وتعهد بالقضاء
على ترامب واعتقد ان هذا هو قرار سياسي
وليس قرار بالفعل بالطبع ترامب رئيس ورجل
له مخالفات كثيره ويجب ان يخضع للقانون
لكن لا يمكن استثناء او تجاهل البعد
السياسي في هذه القضيه اعتقد ان قدمت
يعني في النهايه الدستور الامريكي يسمح
لاي شخص
مدان او يعني
متهم جنائيا بان يرشح نفسه للانتخابات وان
يكون رئيس الا طبعا في حاله استثنائيه كان
هناك نوع من التمرد العصيان ضد الولايات
المتحده لذلك اريد ان افهم سيد جان فاند
تاثير هذه اثاره هذه القضيه الان وهل فعلا
ستؤثر على حملته الانتخابيه القادمه ام
سيكون بطه عرجاء فيها
هو من الان بطه عرجاء لانه ليس في منصبه
الرسمي لهذا السبب نحن لا يمكن
ان حقيقه نسقط من الاهتمام الذين
[موسيقى]
يتحدثون عن هذه
الاتهامات بامكان المدعي العام دائما ان
يقرر لديه صلاحيات مات من عندما هو هو
يعارض ذلك ويقول ان هذه قضيه زومبي كما
يسمونها ميته حيه
وحتى محامي سابق يقول لان المصداقيه السيد
كاظم سوف تمر امام المحكمه ويستطيع اثبات
موقفه عليك ان تجري استجوابا
لشخص 20 مره ولن تثبت امام انا لا اعتقد
ناس ستصل الى تلك المرحله اعتقد ان قضيه
وثائق الامن القومي هي اكثر اهميه ربما
سنتحدث عن تلك القضيه بعد سته اشهر من
الان هذه القضيه هي سابقه سيئه لان ممثلين
ادعاء العام لديهم مشاعر سيئه وحتى المدعي
العام نفسه في نفس القضيه في العام الماضي
يقول انها خطا
تكون قضيه زومبي يعني في السابق كانت هناك
محاولتين لادانته من مجلس الشيوخ وفشلت
هذه المحاولات هذه المره سيد هل الامر
مختلف وخصوصا ان هناك من يرى ان ترامب
الذي لطالم اعتاد على ان يستفيد من
المواقف المحرجه وان يظهر بمظهر المظلوم
فقط بالعكس يعزز مكانته السياسيه ويخرج
اقوى من السابقه هذه ربما حاله من هذه
حالات ربما يحدث العكس
ان القامه
شعبيته فعلا في استطلاعات قد ارتفعت في
الاسابيع الماضيه بشكل كبير فقد حقق عشره
الى 15 نقطه التقدم وهو متقدم جدا عن مرشح
الاخر وبالتالي يبدا انه قد استفاد في
الانتخابات الاوليه الحزب الجمهوري لكن لا
اعتقد ذلك
يعينه ويفيده لكان مرشح الحزب الجمهوري
للرئاسه وهذا هذا هذا مجرم
تعرض الى اتهامات من حزب الجمهوري وقد خان
بلاده وخاد تمرد ضد الولايات المتحده وبدل
من ادانته
والشجبه والتنحيه فان الحزب الجمهوري احرج
نفسه
بتحالف مع هذا المجرم القاتل
واعتقد انها ماساه لحزب الجمهوري ان
يفعلوا هذا وكما شاهدنا في اسابيع الماضيه
واعتقد هذا يجعل نقل احتمالا بالنسبه
للديمقراطيه
بانتخابات السنه القادمه ليس هناك الواقع
السنه القادمه قد يكون مفيدا له في
انتخابات الاوليه الحزب الجمهوري لكن لكن
في كثير ولايات في انتخابات الرئيسيه ان
هذه السياسته لا اعتقد ان لديه اي فرصه او
فرصه له للفوز لان هذه السياسه لن تكون
طويله كلام من جانب الجمهوريين محمد
المنشاوي تكرر كثيرا سواء اثناء فتره
رئاسه ترامب بعدها انه مجرم وانه ارتكب
الكثير وماذا وكان الرئيس كان في كل مره
يستثمر هذا الموضوع ويخاطب المواطن
الامريكي مباشره ويخرج
كما يقال القطه بسبع ارواح يخرج منها
كشاره من العجين لكن هل استنفذت القطه
ارواحها هذه المره او على وصفه مثلا رئيس
الطفل كما كان يوصف ريجن وكان الى حد ما
حتى اليوم ترامب يوصف بذلك هل صاب ماده
الان الشرخ بحيث انه عطبت
لا اعتقد ذلك ترامب كما اثبتت الايام
والسنوات الماضيه يستغل كل شيء لصالحه هو
نجح منذ البدايه في اسقاط اي نمط يتعلق
بالاخلاق او بالقيم والمبادئ منه هو
استطاع ان يبعد هذه الافكار عنه ويدرك
ويدرك المواطن الامريكي ان ترامب رجل سيء
الاخلاق ووافقوا على ذلك وتم انتخابه ومنذ
الامس في اقل من 24 ساعه جمعت حمله ترامب
الانتخابيه اكثر من خمسه ملايين دولار
دولارات بسبب هذا الاتهام انا جائني مثلما
ملايين الامريكيين فور الاعلان امس رساله
الكترونيه تطالبني بالتبرع لحمل ترامب
لمواجهه
ظلم واضطهاد الدوله العميقه والدوله التي
يحكمها الديمقراطيين التي يرون انها تسيس
هذه القضيه من اجل القضاء على مستقبل
ترامب السياسي فهو يستغل كل شيء وايضا
اعتقد ان هذه الحادثه او هذه الاتهامات
وحتى ادانته لن توقفهم من الانتخابات ولنا
سابقه في التاريخ الامريكي هناك كان مرشح
عام 1920 في الانتخابات حصل وهو في السجن
على مليون صوت تقريبا او 4% من الاصوات
حين ذلك واعتقد ان كل هذا يخدم ترامب
واعتقد ان الديمقراطيون يريدون ان تكون
الانتخابات القادمه عن ترامب وليس عن سجل
بايدن بغض النظر عن من يستفيد سواء كان
ترامب او او بايدن الذي يقول ترامب انه
سينعكس عليه الامر لننظر الى موضوع ربما
اكبر وهو موضوع سمعه الولايات المتحده
نائب الرئيس الامريكي السابق مايك فانس
يقول ان توجيه قائمه اتهام ضد رئيس سابق
يمثل امرا شائرا شائلا ويضيف ان تلك
الاتهامات قد تزيد الانقسام بين
الامريكيين في وقت يجب ان نعمل فيه معا
لمواجهه التحديات والتحديات كبيره
التحديات كبيره في الوقت للعالم كله يتحدث
عن مخاطر حرب نوويه يتحدث عنه حرب
اوكرانيا
قضيه ممثله اباحيه تعود يعني تكون في
الواجهه في قلب السياسه الامريكيه ما
تاثير ما يجري على سياسه الولايات المتحده
على سمعتها على مكانتها دوليا
لهذا السبب
الكثيرون يشعرون بالحيره خاصه الرجل الذي
ادار التحقيق حتى العام الماضي ثم
استقالفه
حسم هذه الخطيئه القضيه وقضيه ان الرؤساء
يمكن ان يدانوا اذا ما واجهه قضيه طبعا
وقال ان ما يقوم به الرئيس ليس مخالفه
للقانون بالطبع الامر عكس ذلك الرئيس خاضع
للقانون لكن هناك ملاحقات لدون ترامب على
مستوى الولايه وعلى المستوى الاتحادي لكن
هناك قضيه هذه المراه وهذا الشيء وقضيه
احداث السادس من يناير قضيه اخرى مختلفه
نسمع قضايا مثلا لها علاقه بحرف وجهه
العداله دفع رشه وما الى ذلك والناس
يتفاعلون معها هي قضيه الجنحه
مقابل قضيه
الانتخابات في 2016
منذ سبع سنين قليل الكثير من الوقت اذا
سمحت اريد ان انقل ايضا السؤال لسايمن
روزنبرغ في هذا الخصوص ما تاثير برايك ما
يجري على صوره الولايات المتحده سواء في
الداخل او في الخارج
ليس هناك اي شيء بانثرام قام بضرر كبير ضد
على صوره الولايات المتحده ولسنوات طويله
ومن الواضح انها فكره ان
شخصا ما يبدو انه
يتناقض ولا يؤمن بهما
برؤيته العالم على عكس ما يراه العالم
وكيف انه وبالتالي وهو مستعد
لكسر القانون وبشكل حتى علني دون احترام
القانون وهذا هذا ليس صوره امريكا في
العالم وانها لمسات للزب الجمهوري حزب
ريجن ان حزبه هذا يقف خلفه
لمحمد المنشاوي يجيبنا على اي رساله ترى
انت انا هذه القضيه ترسلها
بالطبع هي ترسل رساله سيئه للخارج حول
الولايات المتحده لكن هذا ليس من جديد
فصول ترامب للحكم كان رساله ايضا سلبيه
للعالم لكن امريكا اكثر تعقيدا واكثر قوه
من ذلك هي متحده في تحديها للعلاقه
الصينيه الروسيه والنموذج الاستبداد الذي
تقدمه ثاني الدولتين وتعمل بقيه الدوله
بكفاءه لكن هي مدينه الفضائح ومدينه عدم
الكفاءه في النظام الامريكي لكن القوه
الكبيره الاخرى الامريكيه سواء في نيويورك
او كاليفورنيا او تكساس او في اي مكان
تعمل بكفاءه وهذا هو سبب القوى الامريكيه
المستمره والتي لا يؤثر فيها شان داخلي
مثل ادانه رئيس او حتى سجنه ان حدث اشكرك
محمد المنشاوي من واشنطن واشكر كذلك جون
فان من اعيدا وشكرا جزيلا لسايمن روزنبرغ
كنت معنا من واشنطن شكرا جزيلا لكم جميعا
مشاهدينا الكرام على متابعه هذه الحلقه من
برنامج مواقع الخبر
[موسيقى]